let's start with the issue of i never
made calls to the press about my
brother's situation
you did
right no
i never contacted any media who were
covering my brother to try to affect
their coverage chris cuomo denying he
tried to influence media coverage of his
brother then new york governor andrew
cuomo it's been a hard
several months on news nation's dan
abrams live his first tv interview since
he was fired from cnn the tv journalist
addresses the controversies surrounding
his exit chris's firing came after he
was suspended when texts and emails
surfaced indicating he may have used his
sources to help his brother build a
legal defense against multiple
allegations of sexual harassment and
misconduct but you said i never made
calls to the press about my brother's
situation you did make calls to the
press about your brother's situation but
i think the distinction the distinction
has a meaningful difference there was a
curiosity at the time by my brother's
team obviously of what was coming next
who was writing what yes okay the idea
that i never spoke to anybody in the
media about my brother it's an
impossibility most of my friends are in
the media and in the aftermath for chris
being called disgraced after his firing
wasn't easy for him your kids
your loved ones
uh they have to wear that badge as well
that's
a double-edged sword for me because you
know growing up that way with my father
and then my brother
i had always told myself
i'm not going to do it this way i never
wanted to be in politics but
i want to let my kids be their own
people and then here i am and
there's regret that goes along with that
still the media personality says he's
got nothing but love for his brother the
rule in my family is very simple
family trouble
go
um
other people have the luxury of judging
allegations and situations
um for me it was about helping my
brother in a hard way and doing it in a
way that i didn't thought think
compromise what matters
and
that's what guided me
i am very proud of my brother i love my
brother chris filed an unlawful
termination lawsuit against cnn alleging
that he was wrongfully terminated based
on false claims that he defied
journalistic ethics in the meantime he's
moving forward and making his big return
to tv news on a new prime time show i
want to find a way to help people i'm
going to come to this nation
and i want to build something special
here
uh work with dan work with the team here
they've got great people who are really
hungry to make a difference in ways that
i think matter
[Music]